After we have fixed the program we need to check two things.
First, we need to check whether the same error has been made elsewhere.
In our case, if there is a programmer who has confused the precedence
of ors and ands, it may be a good thing to check the code for other places,
and to make sure that all of these have proper parentheses around them,
which anyway is a good programming practice.
Second, we want to make sure that the error does not occur again.
and we can do so either by writing appropriate tests, see the other Udacity
course for how to do that.
Or, we can include appropriate assertion in the code that makes sure the error will not occur again.